this really is Big because Finland is a
very significant country in a military
sense it's got a small army but when it
mobilizes it has an army of over 200 000
and that's three times bigger than the
British army so they've got big land
forces and they train and they're well
equipped and they mean it uh finland's
been uh independent since 1945 and this
switching in finland's posture is a very
big deal for NATO the Russians invaded
Finland and the winter War so-called
winter war of 1939-40 was a war that the
Finns lost but they've they fought the
Russians very very hard indeed and the
Russians were found they couldn't
conquer Finland and they took a section
of it and as a result of that Finland
got itself involved in uh German working
with the Nazis a little bit
um in the second world war and then at
the end of the war became determinedly
neutral so finland's been neutral since
1945. Sweden has been neutral since 1812
and both of them now want to become
members of NATO so and since 1945 the
Finns have been very careful in the way
they react to Russia they've played
Russia very carefully
um by not pushing the diplomacy too far
uh trying to make sure that Russians
were happy with everything they did that
was the case all through the Cold War
and now since 1991 finland's been much
more independent and now they're so
independent they think that they can
join NATO
how do you think the man we're looking
at now Vladimir Putin is going to take
this news well he pretends not to care
but he cares very much because this has
actually added another 830 odd miles uh
1300 kilometers of of NATO territory or
NATO border with Russia so it means that
any Russian leaders defense requirements
are now a bit different it gives him
something to to bother about and a
bigger Frontier to worry about if he
worries about these things but he
pretends that it doesn't really matter
they'll take whatever mean measures they
need to take to counter it but actually
there's not nothing the Russians can do
and they don't have enough troops to be
able to really pack this Frontier
um because they're sending all of their
available troops to Ukraine so this is I
mean this is the biggest development in
European security since the
um the re-militarization of Germany in
1955 when Germany came into NATO as a
re-militarized state after the second
world war you know this is the biggest
NATO enlargement the most importantly to
enlargement since then and President
Putin can say what he likes about it the
fact is uh this is a a big diplomatic
defeat for him which you know has
produced exactly what he said this war
was designed to prevent which was uh
NATO enlargement well isn't one of the
the reasons that he gave for the
invasion of Ukraine the fact that NATO
was on the Russian doorstep which it
wasn't Ukraine was not a member of NATO
and they kept saying it never will be
even though it wants to be it will take
a long time and now you've got the Finns
joining up in Sweden sure to follow yeah
exactly so it's me it's made Russia's
security situation much worse than it
was originally
um and that's not going to change in the
in the short term uh and the fact is
that that um I mean Putin had several
motives for this Ukrainian War but one
of the motives he started to float as
the war got closer was that this was all
about pushing NATO back and telling NATO
that it it can't keep taking on new
members and remember that the new
members of NATO were were this was all
German driven NATO didn't want to
enlarge itself it just was responding to
requests very strong requests by the
state in Europe that wanted to join NATO
um and Putin sort of assumed that NATO
was was behind all of this but it wasn't
really it was just responding to demands
from other other countries and so here
we are now with a situation where NATO
is bigger than it's ever been before
stronger than it's been in many many
years militarily and politically and
Russia's in a situation where it can't
do very much about that